Heeeeey!
How's it going bros?
Welcome back to Resident Evil 7
I didn't think I'd be playing this so soon again
buut- haha
They released a DLC called-
oh, there's two out, okay.
We'll start with Banned Footage
That's a pretty good title
HERE WEE GOOO
I guess-
They could've just released this with the main title
Thinking how soon they...
Released it... but uhh
I appreciate the extra content
It's always fun to revisit a game that you finished
And hey, y'know if I don't have to wait that long in between...
I'll take it!
Let's play....
Nightmare
What the f*ck is this?
Woah
ahh
eeugh
This feels like the demo-
OH my god
What is happening?
wut?
oh no
oh no no no
Survive until dawn
What does that mean?
What the f*ck, is this zombies?
I'll take the shotgun
And i'll take some shotgun shells
How much do I have left?
We're doing alright
Now we start off- Safety first everyone!
'Compactors produce a steady amount of scrap'
Excellent
OOOHHHH Let the games begin, bro!
OH we're in the- ohh i hate this
f*cking area
What is this? Until Dawn rip off?
alright
Okay I got it
How do- I can't open anything
Now I can
F*ck, this is creepy, dude.
This is well creepy
Jesus Christ
There's a bomb there!
Can we activate it?
Hundred wires
Okay so far no enemies but we're doing okay
How much scrap have we made? A hundred, okay
Maybe we can install this turret now
okay
This is a lot different than I thought it would be. What the f*ck is happening?
Shotgun is the way to go man
F*ck everything else
500 or 600?
OH SHIT OH SHIT OH SHIT
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
Great
Fantastic
Okay well
I think this is a really fun time waster
Like if you wanna play more of Resident Evil
That's a really cool way to play
But I think what we're after is to play some-
Ｔｈｅ　Ｂｅｄｒｏｏｍ
Which I think is more of a story-oriented thing
I'm not sure though
Man, that got me-
That got me going man. I forgot-
I forgot how f*cking freaky this game is
Oh sh*t, what is happening here?
See- yeah, this is definitely what I wanted to play
Okay
That's cool a little bonus
Oh god
It's never a good way to wake up, is it?
Never a good way- at least we have one hand free
We can still fap
We can still fap everyone! We're f-
EEE MOMMY
You made me breakfast
OH YAH MOMMY
Oh! She- ohh
ohh... well-
whoops
umm..I'm actually full
aha I had a snickers
IT SMELLS SOOO GOOD
But I- this is embarrassing
okay..okay..alright
WOW THAT LOOKS DELICIOUS
I could probably take her- take her in a
Tana Mongeau choke-hold if she's that close y'know and if I have one hand free
'Is there anything else to eat?'
What the f*ck?
I'll eat yo ass if you come back late-
ohh..okay..alright
Well, I guess we gotta eat
I guess we can...
ESCAPE FROM THE ROOM das righht
I love these kind of escape sh*t it's so cool
Okay, we got a spoon!
No fucking shit, dude
Alright, so, there's a puzzle
We just gotta use ahahaha
well that was easy
okay
Hey aren't you gonna eat-
Ey a lamp
OHHH, Amnesia the dark descent!
There is something on the- a puzzle on the..
Lighter
Okay
That might be useful.
A strong pull might get it open
Okay.. some satanic altars
I'm assuming this door doesn't even open
Alright, we're just gonna chec-
Shh, I know, I know, Ethan Bradberry
An Untitled painting
aYY, it's a spiders
But they will attack me
We need the lighter
OH my god
Well use the-
Oh, for f*cks sake pls
Uhh
The lighter
Bye-bye, spiders!
I need something hotter
Okay, so we need to lit something, maybe
What is this?
I can-
HI PEWDIEPIE
I THINK YOU MIGHT REMEMBER ME
IT'S ME,
JACKSEPTICEYE
I MISSED YOU FROM MY-
God-
I can't-
Really, I can't do anything?
I can just-
OKAY
Well that's just good fun
Hey, it's a watch
It's a high quality watch!
Okay, uhh
Oh, there's a lot of stuff to investigate
Some kind of door beneath the bed
Oh yeah
We're in Granny's room
Maybe we can dig something out of the food?
Ohh, what a lovely food.
REALLY?
NN-
NNNNN-
NOOOoo
What did you think?
What wou-
I'll have another spoon, please.
Shut the f*ck up.
This is cool, I like this.
Alright, uhh painting-
Oh, okay we get into the clock
OH MY GOD
Okay, and then set the- another painting?
AYY
WOAH
Oh sh*t
Granny's gonna come back, isn't she?
F*ck
f*ck f*ck
Let's go back
let's go back
Nothing, Granny! :D
Just enjoying my food! :D
Did I have to hide the lantern again?
Sh*t.
Maybe I should've hidden the lantern
Oh my god, I f*cked up
Okay, uhh
I just realized
f*ck.
Oh god
Put it back!
OH my god!
Oh my god
Wait, wait
wait
wait WAAAAAAIT D:
I might f*ck up here, I don't- I-
maybe I- did I forget something?
HEEEY
It's you!
No-
'Now hold on-'
Now, excuse me, heh
Uh-oh
Uh-oh!
OOOOOH
OHH
DON'T F*CK ME, MOMMY ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
NOO
AAHHH
AAHHHH-
EUUUUUUGH
WHAT THE FUU*K
OH MY GOD
IT'S A DOUBLE DILDO! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
`д´
OH
OH, DUDE
OH, my controller's shaking like crazy!
Oh my god
Y'know, I- I enjoyed that
I am happy to die there
Okay, so
The drawer didn't open up by itself
Okay, I'm not quite sure, like, what I need to do
Just-
Okay
Put the drawer back in
I suppose she won't mind if I take this.
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING, MOMMY :C
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING >:C
My god
Oh my god
Is she coming in, or what?
hEEY
How are you?
Oh?
'Now hold on-' I love how she talks
"Now"
"hold on"
Thank you, mommy, and may I say
your a- anus tasted delightful ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I finished the whole thing
(ఠ◞౪◟ఠ)
I know, but you see-
Aw, of course, mommy
I'll-
I- I hope so!
Cus I'm not doing anything
weird at all, are we? haha.
Trick that b*tch.
GOOOT'EM
Alright, we're goin' out
This is stressing me out
I don't know, the element of someone just randomly appearing while you're fiddling with sh*t, man ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
It reminds me of when I was a kid.
Get the lantern
okay
Now, what do we got?
We got one painting
Then we know there's one painting over here
Oh god, shu- *burp* t up spiders
Sorry, I-
Okay
We got a painting there, Painting C
Shit, did I-?
Oh, f*ck
Okay, uhh
That obviously goes there
And
You know
Ah
Oh my god
oh my god
What is that?
'Sewing needle'
Can I close this?
Uhh, how?
Okay okay, I can
Okay
okay
Let's put it back
Let's put it all back, uhh
I think-
circle one there, right?
Let's- Just in case
Just in case
I'm gunna put you back as well
Cus I aint trusting anyone and I- you ugly spiders
Needle
What was it?
Sewing needle
That's- looks..
I don't think it'd make a very good weapon
I was not about to think that..
We can put it in there
Same as all the other clocks, of course
okay, so
I don't know what the f*ck the time was...
F*ck, I should've made a note, shouldn't I?
Okay, I can still enter
Okay, so it's-
Twelve..It's five.
Five in the morning?
Can I read the time?
I don't- I don't know
Okay
Let's just- let's just do this
and see what happens
That looks like a pregnancy test thing
Not that I would know what that that would look like..
Ah..
Oh?
Oh Mommy..
Oh Mommy,  what have I done?
Eh..what the f*ck?
aaa
NOT ME, MOMMY D:
NOT ME, MOMMY!
Fuck..Okay.
Lets make sure that we don't f*ck up
NO!
GO BACK!
Stupid bed
I wonder how she'll react if-
Oh god..we have to put this back as well, I forgot. Shit..
Fuck
This is freaking me out dude
This is freaking me out..
Mommy? ;-;
Get yo' fat ass in here girl ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Get yo' sexy ass-
Yeah..
Hey
Oh, you got me a treat, Mommy ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Why- What do you have for me this time girl
She knows just what I like
Her milk juice
That is disgusting..I am sorry, what is wrong with me
Thank you, Mommy. It was delicious
Smells just like you, Mommy
Awww! No..you shouldn't have
Oh?
Oh
Oh..
Nnnoooo..
NN-
Uh-oh Uh-oh
Sh*t, I thought I-
I thought-
EUGHH *weird laugh*
Yeah
Oh why thank you
Thank- Thanks
*weird laugh again*
Ohhh! A fork!
Thank you, Mommy
F*ckin' bi*ch I f*cking hate her! D:<
What do we got
Hey dude dont make comments for me
Hey, a fork
A stove
We should at least try it ya know..its the polite thing to do
That is probably a paprika
*barf sound*
*more barf sounds*
Why is that an option *laughing*
To try it.. *still laughing*
You lose a little bit of health to thats cool
Okay so
Tha- I noticed there was something on the floor. There was a sign wasn't it
Inspect it
That's not the inspect tool
There it is.
Okay so..Snake
Uhh..
Whats on this?
Apple
Okay whats the third one though
legit don't know what the third one is but perhaps we can just guess it
So..
I mean Im just guessing at this point..
Its not a very good way to do it is it?
Okay, f*ck. Okay
We' We're gonna have to rethink..
Uhh..
Is there any form of cutlery in here
Do we have any other cutlery from Mommy
F*ck I dont know
What can I possibly do..
Maybe the needle. Is there something-
No..
"It needs fuel"
For f*cks sake..
Okay where do we find fuel for a f*cking lighter
Du- Theres all kinds of sh*t here dude
Come on man
Maybe we can break open with-
Thats so-
Oh no..
Oh f*ck
Are you serious?
It may be broken
Im f*cked now
Im f*cked because this thing wont go back!
NOOO
AYYE
GOT EM
Okay, okay
We're fine
What do we got in here
Okay we got a  cinema
We gotta-
Ohh another one of these
"the lantern hook is fixed to the wall by a cork"
A cork huh
Heyya
This is the key we needed right?
Okay
Ok
OOOkay
Fork
GO FORK..!
How am I doing that *laughs*
Tha- That didnt make any sense at all haha
YES! We need that
Close. Close it. Close it
Okay and then we close this door
We close everything
We dont change anything. Mommy doesn't like change
(throwin' shade) Mommy is just like precious YouTube commentary
"Pewdiepie changed his hair I dont like it" (callin' everyone out)
Unsub
Wait do I have to-
I have to combine them first
Yes Sir!
Yes baby yes baby sexus Texas drop me and you burn them f*cking spidas  (?)
Hell yeah!
Goodbye!
OHH! F*ck
Uh-oh
Oh..Oh
Ah..Ah..Uh. I wasnt doing anything bad
I KNOW!
I know we have to get back!
Gotta get back, shake that ass
Okay. I believe that was it
Oh my god. Im so paranoid right now. Did I-
Did we lock the door after us
How much time do we have
F*ck
F*ck im going to be so pissed if I f*ck it up now
Well.neither am I motherf*cka
Please dont look at the lock
Now hold on..dont look at that lock
*Begging not to look at the lock*
Uh-Oh..Uh-Oh
Ohh! The f*cking drawer
Ah..F*ck sake..
I was just spreading my-
I can touch your titties. I get it ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Uhh..It was Lucas
Please God. Please work
EEha
I just- I just clenched my ass Jesus (ok)
I thought that was so strange. Like you-
She is 100% going to kill us bros
Shes 100% going to kill us
*burp*
You know I would just find a way to kill myself at this point because honestly, Im- Im not to happy about this
Okay I couldnt even put the lock back so there was no way.
F*cking drawer. You f*cked me dude!
Drawer: F*ck you pewdiepie. I focking hate ya. You f*cking suck. You used to be better before now all you do is complain *draw continues to speak trash..*
Ahh..Oh yeah the cork screw. Okay okay Okayyy
Why am I doing this
How am I doing this?
Am I rite? Heheha. How am I doing that with my other arm
I dont even know why I need that..
I cant place it back. F*ck
Aw sh*t
ah great..
*That music though ;)*
How the f*ck was I supposed to find this
Are you f*cking kidding me
Thats ridiculous
Okay
Now that we have the knife
We can cut up the tape
Excellent.
Beautiful
oh... I so satisfy to do that
every time
guess put the lantern
thaan
Oh wow
Yeah that's look.. ah.. that's look correct
You're fork (wat?)
oh god this is hard (srsly?)
so sensitive
Yeahya
Aha
I say ya..  I said Yeya
OK next one
Don't have lot of time bros
We don't have a lot of time
oh God
Oh god im scared
I'M..
Oh f*ck its upside down, shit, shit, shit, shit.. Here we go
Hey
YEAAHh
High five Braaa
yeah
that was a little awkward i'm sorry
let's take this back
to where it belong
take da shnake key
and get f*ck out of...
oh no
(dat face)
Aaahh...
I'd used a knife
NO!
NOO!
YEEESS!
*laugh*
OH MY GOD
Granny i'm sorry (i'm sure he planned to kill old bitch)
STOP SCREAMING
F*CK
I KNOW IT HURTS
WTF it hurts me to Mommy
I'M Sorry MOM
Where f*ck is da key?
AAAaaaaaaahhh
OH SHIT SHIT
NOOO!
I don't even see anything!
I'M Sorry Mommy! I lOVE You! ( so cute)
I love you...
Yeeesss!
That was so cool
Fuck YEAH!
Coming soon
Alright
That was realy fun! I realy enjoy that
I hope You enjoy as well
If you did plz drop a like i'll appreciate that
And as always let me know if you wanna do Ethan..
I think that was calling Ethan's diary or something like that
Anyway
Thank you for watching
Stay awesome BROS